my favorite Oscar moment has got to be  the streaking the the great one the the  streaker behind David Niven on stage two  there was a naked man ashlee running  past by him and now to divulge the  contents of this year's most important  envelope is a very important contributor  to world entertainment and someone quite  likely they were never just kind of kept  on going  I remember when that when that happened  and streaking was a part of our world  and you actually had to worry that  somebody might come through your world  suddenly naked and then it happened in  Oscars name gentlemen that come that was  almost bound to happen but isn't it  fascinating that fascinating you think  the probably the only love that man will  ever get in his life is by stripping off  and showing his shortcomings